[MUSIC PLAYING]
This is about the felt
feeling of collectivity
or the sort of shared feeling.
This is about something
bigger than just
being in that space,
looking at this work of art.
When you see water falling,
you also see time passing.
And when you see
time passing, you
see a different kind of space.
What a waterfall can do is add
an element of temporal quality,
an element of
inclusivity, an element
for a possibility to share an
experience, a shared space.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
It's a great thing if
you can somehow combine
singularity and collectivity.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The presence of other
people in the piece
plays a central role
for your experience.
What is it that makes a space
challenging, and exciting,
and embracing, and including,
and hospitable, and intolerant,
and so on?
What is that?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
About 10 years ago, I had an
exhibition here at the Tate
called The Weather
Project, where
I had something like a very
big sun in the Turbine Hall.
It also became about the
people which were in the space,
and about the feeling
of being in that space.
I've now for a
while been working
on an idea for a
work of art, which
is this little thing here.
I call it Little Sun.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
A solar panel, a container,
light on the other side.
I charge it.
Four hours of charging gives
you five hours of light.
Most people who
don't have energy,
they rely on kerosene
for lighting.
Kerosene, of course,
is unhealthy.
This one is 10 times
cheaper than kerosene.
It has 10 times more light,
but gives you 100 times
better performance.
Light is social.
Light is life.
This is about strength, and
about power, and about energy,
about happiness and love, and
that's the same for everybody.
This is energy for all.
[MUSIC PLAYING]